so when we think of students we might
not think of athletes but one thing i've
learned over the years is that if you
want to perform well it's better to
think of yourself as an athlete studying
is like a race and not a sprint as in
you need to perform at your best in
multiple instances in a year and to keep
up this grueling student lifestyle it is
good to learn from our fellow top
performers athletes so hi i'm schloss
fraser a second year phd student in
computational neuroscience at the
dunhurst institute in the netherlands
and i read a book this week called peak
performance how to elevate your game and
i love some of the lessons that they
taught me in this book and i want to
share them with you today so let's get
right into it so the first lesson they
talked about is about stress plus rest
equals growth and i really like this
concept i think as students we have the
stress part down but the problem is
usually the rest part for a lot of us so
i think that usually when people think
of rest they think of chilling in front
of the tv and just binge watching a lot
of movies or just lying down on your bed
but actually in the book he talks a lot
about active rest for athletes an active
rest is not this idea that you just lie
down to rest but that you do small
things that really
activate you in some way that are not
too strenuous so for example i think
when i think of rest of reading a book
or seeing friends or being out in nature
and these are things where you're
actually not fully resting but which
kind of distracts you from studying and
i think this rest plus stress equals
growth is a really good formula to
optimize for peak performance so the
next thing he talks about is purposely
designing your day for peak performance
and for example athletes they really
follow strict training regimens or
training schedules and i think as
students we can kind of learn from that
so for example waking up at the same
time every day closing off your day at
the same time and also scheduling or
chunking periods of peak performance
throughout the week and i would also
here schedule in resting days such that
you can really optimize your stress and
your rest the third thing he talks about
is consistency is key so instead of
thinking of i want to achieve this in
one week it's better to think about how
you are gonna perform every day so for
example you would every day work for two
hours on a really difficult topic and i
think by being consistent in this manner
we can achieve way bigger outputs than
when we really put emphasis on trying to
finish one thing in one day the fourth
thing he talks about is the power of
meditation and the mind body connection
and i find this really important in dr
huberman's in his podcast he also talks
a lot about this about the brain body
connection and we sometimes neglect our
body especially when we try to study
really hard but it's good to keep your
body healthy and also your mind through
meditation for example and by applying
this we can actually achieve better
studying results than just fully
studying for an entire day so something
that i adopted which i heard from the dr
hubermann's podcast as well is this kind
of tea meditation and i really like this
because meditating in general is really
hard for me but by combining it with
this mindfulness of having a little tea
ceremony every day i think it's easier
to implement during my day and then the
fifth thing he talks about is to develop
and harness your purpose and i think
this is maybe the most important thing
so purpose is usually not a direct goal
but more an overlying theme in your
entire life so for example for me my
purpose in general is to become wise in
some manner or to become a renaissance
man woman and that's just to say that i
really like learning and i don't only
like learning in my own field but from
all topics and in this manner usually
when i make choices i think about if it
fits this general purpose of learning
curiosity and wisdom and if it does then
i would go that way and i think it's
really good to think about your purpose
in general in life so not your direct
goal of for example graduating but what
do you want to do with this knowledge
who do you want to help what are the
next steps you want to take after so
yeah this was a super short video on
peak performance and i hope you learned
a little bit about how to optimize your
day and life to get to this peak
performance i would definitely recommend
you to check out the book as well and if
you have any tips or tricks for me i
would love to hear them so put them down
in the comments below and otherwise see
you next week bye